AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT GAME,
ORANGE ACCOUNTY.
A REDDITOR NAMED OLIGARCHY
OLIGARCHY POSTED AN IMAGE
WITH THE CAPTION "UPS DRIVER
LEFT $0.75 AFTER PICKING UP AN
ORANGE FROM MY FRONT YARD."
I PAY FOR ONE ORANGE, 75 CENT.
NOW, THE ILLOGICAL USE OF THE
FIRST PERSON SIMPLE PRESENT
TENSE, THE LACK OF PUNCTUATION,
AND THE STRANGELY AUTHORITATIVE
DEMOCRAT DECLARATION AS TO THE
MARKET VALUE OF SAID ORANGE, I
THINK WE MIGHT BE LOOKING AT A
RUSSIAN SPY DEAD DROP.
SO COMEIDANS, TONIGHT'S SPEED
GAME, I WOULD LIKE YOU TO GIVE
ME SOME OTHER NOTES FROM THIS
ODD, POSSIBLY SOVIET UPS DRIVER.
I PUT SECOND 60 ON CLOCK AND GO.
PAUL F.
>> YOU WILL ALL PAY FOR ONE
ORANGE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
TOM.
>> I LOOK UP WHAT ORANGES COST.
YOU OWE $0.30.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. PAGET.
>> I STARE WISTFULLY AT YOUR SON
AND WISH MY SON HAD NOT DIED.
$3.
>> CHRIS: POINTS, POINTS. TOM.
>> THE GAME HAS CHANGED, MY
FRIEND.
I ATE YOUR ORANGE. AND NOW YOU
PAY ME 75 CENTS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. PAUL F.
>> ORANGE YOU GLAD I DIDN'T KILL
YOU WHILE YOU SLEEPING?
>> CHRIS: POINTS. YES, TOM.
>> HEY.
IT'S THE UPS GUY AGAIN.
I WAS WANDERING IF YOU WILL READ
SOME OF MY EROTIC FICTION.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.